here with reaction former energy
secretary texas governor rick perry
governor i asked you last time i said
if we include oil include gas include
coal you said well over a hundred years
worth of supply with new technology for
example microwaving shale or oil uh
is it possibly even much longer than
that
potentially and when you add uh small
modular
reactors in there it's for
longer than the
anyone has a look into the future
sean
we knew this
was coming
as soon as we saw the biden
administration start
putting a stop to our fossil fuel
production in the united states
we knew that the russians were going to
use
energy as a weapon
we talked about it ad nauseum over in
europe when we were delivering american
liquefied natural gas
we were basically calling it freedom uh
gas and it's exactly what it was uh
we're seeing
uh the reality
of reckless disregard
of reality and that's what this
administration is doing reckless
disregard for reality the reality was
when you gave the russians
the weapon of energy
they're going to use it and let me tell
you i'll give you a great example um
alex novak was the former minister of
energy i met with him while i was his
counterpart at the department of energy
as the secretary of energy and
he has now become the deputy prime
minister
and he literally said yesterday i
believe that if
sanctions were put into place
that they would cut off the gas into the
european union exactly what we told uh
the members of the european union that
they would do if they finished that
nordstrom 2 pipeline president trump
stood up
you know had the gumption and the vision
to say we're not going to do that we're
going to stop that we're going to
sanction these folks if
it goes forward and it stopped and it
gave europe
a real taste of
independence
from russian
pressure and and now they're they're
back in the uh the sights of the of
putin and he's squeezing the trigger
let me ask you that uh governor mr
secretary let me ask you this you just
heard peter ducey say that the left has
they want a fossil fuel-free america
so
they're willing to not they're forcing
america to negotiate with some of the
most hostile regimes in the world we're
literally now in the middle of a war
importing all this energy from russia
we're now apparently negotiating even
with the muellers of iran that chant
often death to israel death to america
now we're going to go to the
dictatorship of venezuela they've
already been rejected by opec opec over
and over again to increase production
we're going to allow americans to suffer
a 40-year high of inflation
and have a weaker national security
because of our dependence on foreign
energy uh can you tell me how any of
that makes any sense in any way to you
negotiating with mad men
is not a good look and that's exactly
what we're doing
this administration
does not
either they have
again
this is a reckless disregard for reality
the reality is uh madura
the uh the uh
anatolia the uh the iranians they're
they're not going to negotiate in good
faith with us
the russians are going to do every thing
they can to put us into
the greatest pickle that they can put us
in and china sitting on the sidelines
are
somewhat on the sidelines
watching this
and deciding whether or not they're
going to attack taiwan i mean
we're getting into a real mess here sean
and this administration doesn't seem to
be doing anything in the reality side of
it because reality is this
stand up
mr president and admit you were wrong
push back on your woke left climate
crazies and say you know what folks your
plan just wasn't gonna work an american
energy producers we're going to remove
the regulations that are stifling you
and don't be confused about uh standing
up and
and pasaki saying we got 9 000 permits
like that matters those oil and gas
individuals when they know that they can
make a profit they will be out there
drilling but they know they can't today
because the american government the
federal government is their enemy
and until the message is sent listen
we were wrong please come back and start
drilling for the oil and gas that we've
got in this country and bring america
and the rest of the world that's on our
side
back to energy independence and we can
do that we just need the signal from the
federal government that we're not just
going to strangle you
uh i can't believe the times we're
living in secretary rick perry boy uh we
really could use you back as energy
secretary thank you for being with us
and we could use the oil and the natural
resources of your great state of texas
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else